hello everyone welcome back to the
capablanca saga
now we'll mostly a bonus video for the
Capablanca saga we already finished the
1914 tournament of sang Peter Berg from
Kappa Blancas perspective we have
covered all of the games that were
played and you already know if you've
seen my previous video that it was
actually a manual ask her who won that
event now in the final round
Blanca played against Alexander I think
you want a very nice game and it all now
depends on how Lasker will play in the
final round against Frank James Marshall
so we already mentioned if Lasker wins
Alaska wins the entire event which we
already know happened but it's very
interesting what approach he took
against Marshall in this game so and I
did not receive my boob Isaac Roberta
rush about this beautiful event but I
have received a message from Amazon that
it has finally shipped so we're gonna be
enjoying it you know a fairly soon and
some of insightful comments by dr.
Siebert are as I said we will most
likely be returning to this tournament
at some point or the other
Albert game as you can see in the quote
above the board in order to persuade him
to come to the tournament the committee
have paid him over 4000 rubles I do not
consider this excessive so as you know
the price for first place in this
tournament is 1,200 rubles which last
group won but also just to come to this
tournament he was paid more than three
times that worth so as it says over
4,000 rubles so quite quite a lot of
money
Alaska made this tournament but okay
let's check out the game as that's what
we're here for and also if you haven't
check out the link in the description
below it will take you to a voting poll
as you are more than welcome to decide
on the time format for my weekly
tournament that will be held unleashes
every week in the same time barking get
him back to the game Alaska has the
white pieces and he opens with E for we
have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight sorry
Knight to f6 he goes for the better of
defense this game Knight captures on e5
by Lasker the classical variation d6
Knight to f3 and not Knight captures on
e4 and Queen e2 we already seen this
line in this tournament Queen to e7 and
now
three night of six you can see that the
tension is here but white wants black
the capture black ones white the capture
to help out with the development of its
own pieces butter up to g5 Bishop to e6
and not Knight to c3
dopamine's are not getting traded off
Knight B to d7 by Marshall and the last
rib roast for queenside castle with h6
asking Alaska what what's your idea with
the bishop here do we want to capture do
we want to retreat Bishop to h4 is
played and out g5 Bishop to g3 and nice
to h5 marshal wants to get rid of
Lasker's a dark square Bishop and we
have d4 by Lasker with ideas of maybe
going d5 but also it frees the be five
square for Alaska's Queen so the Queen
and the bishop can get nicely developed
first Knight captures and g3 are getting
rid of Alaska strong dark square Bishop
H captures and g3 and now G for kicking
the knight back with Knight to h4 and
now d5 marshal doesn't want a lot of d5
from Lasker so he pushes d5 himself and
also this opens up at the before square
for marshal squint if needed but Oscar
takes the initiative first he goes Queen
to b5 and now you can see that there's
an attack against the b7 pawn but also
there's an attack against the the d5
pawn so what do you do here
a marshal made a very interesting
decision here marshal decided to cast
him inside and he sets a deadly trap for
Lasker what's the idea ken Ken Lasker
capture on d5 now this is the position
imagine your Alaska marshal just castled
against you and you know you have to win
this game if you want to win the
tournament and you know everything is
underlined can you capture the d5 pawn
and the Watts marshals idea behind it
feel free to pause the video here and
you know ponder on this moment and
decide the best course of action for
white I'll give you a couple seconds as
usual for those of you that decided that
it's okay to grab the d5 pawn you would
actually be losing a game if you did
this because after Knight captures the
black queen is under attack so there's
no time for any sis c6 idea so you would
have to capture and after queen capture
this is
marshals idea Queen g5 check forces
white the tree
Queens otherwise you're gonna lose the
Queen Queen captures pawn captures and
you lose the knight on h4 the knight
cannot move as rook captures rook
well the rook on h1 is undefended so
here you would have to play anything but
let's say but should be three characters
captures and Alaska and the marshal
would just be up a knight so not
something you want to do world champion
Emanuel Lasker doesn't fall for for this
he goes Queen to a5 now with threats of
capturing an a7 and here it's a very
important decision that Marshall has to
make does he go a six does he go kink to
b8 how do you defend King B it is very
interesting if King BH then might be
five threatens to capture here and then
you would have to go a six at some point
but then comes Queen captures on c7 and
the reason this is this is an
interesting defense for black is because
after King eight you now have two well
it removed the Queen or protect the
night between f5 doesn't allow the pond
to capture the night and now you just go
back in b8 so now here Alaska cannot of
course repeat moves if he doesn't want a
draw he would have to go for something
like tonight here look to see it with a
double attack Knight captures F captures
and you would get this position where
Alaska grabs a pawn and the game
continues but it's not not something
really what you want to go for so
instead of this line after Queen to a5
Marshall decides to go for a different
line he goes a six immediately prevents
Queen captures on a seven this way but
now Alaska just you know goes all out he
decides to sacrifice the bishop for an
attack well okay it's a bishop for two
pawns but I mean still it is a sacrifice
Bishop captures on e6 pawn captures on
a6 in Queen captures an a6 with check
King the b8 and now comes Knight to b5
threatening Queen to a7 checks followed
by Queen a8
and also by playing Knight to b5 you
also make room for this very nice rook
lift
Knights to b6 by Marshall if now Queen
starts checking then the King can
perhaps escape via these squares but
rook to d3 Alaska just you know plays it
cool it increases the pressure and see
what Marshall does if you try something
like Queen d7 good ideas of trading
Queens it doesn't work because now
you're just
remove the d7 square from the black King
to use as an escape route after Queen a7
chair King see it
rooks III will be deadly there's nothing
for black to do here the thread is Queen
captures night and of course if you move
the knight to block the rook then just
Queen eight will be checkmate so a very
difficult position for Marshall to be in
Queens the g5 check first by Marshall
King to be one and now Bishop to d6
Marshall just continues developing as
for now Alaska does not have a decisive
move but just rook the b3 + R increases
the pressure puts a rook on a very
important file we have rook hd8
preparing ideas that after the bishop
moves Queen to d2 and the rook to e1
will be a plan for Marshall we have a
formal Oscar preparing a five and now
just Bishop to f5 Alaska decides to
first play Knights to a seven that's
right now is Knight to c6 which will be
checkmate as the Queen is covering these
squares so you have to protect the c6
square the bishop has to go back Bishop
to d7 is played and now just a five wins
the piece there's nothing to do about
this but okay Queen to d2 Marshall tries
anything to start any sort of a
counter-attack a capture Sun b6 we have
rook to e1 check and hero lass Rogers
goes King to a two with with some crazy
threats here so c6 is played of course
you don't want to allow the opening of
the B file Marshall goes c6 and here
Knights to b5 again with the threats of
Queen to h7 check so we have C captures
on b5 but there's no better move if you
don't capture the night it's over
Marshall played C capture Sun b5 and now
after Queen to a7 check it was in this
position and move 29 that Frank James
Marshall resigned at the game and this
was enough for dr. Emmanuel a score to
win this tournament so why did he resign
here do you see the checkmate it's
amazing to not gonna ask you to pause
the video as there's only one square for
the King King to c8 then comes Queen to
a8 check you would have to block this
Bishop to be 8 and now Queen to a six
will be checkmate as the pawn controls
the c7 square but at Marshall
the the mates to appear on the board so
after Queen is seven check he just
resigned to the game and if you by any
chance you haven't seen my previous
video to check it out I will put a link
to it in the description below but in
case you have let's just repeat it first
place dr. emmanuel asked her second
place holder role kappa blanka alexander
Leah Hinton Ziegler Tosh and Frank James
Marshall those are the five finalists
that went into the second half of the
tournament and then the participants of
the first half of the tournament
Akiba Rubinstein Ossie Bernstein aron
nimzowitsch joseph henry blackburn david
Janoski and Isidor ginsburg with the
points as follow but yet half a point
ahead of host role capablanca and a
wonderful victory for dr. emmanuel asked
her and as you see a very you know
lucrative victory as not only did he win
the first prize money the twelve hundred
rubles also over four thousand roubles
just to get him here to play this
tournament as without Lasker it would be
a very strong tournament but it would
not be the strongest tournament so you
know really the organizers who went all
out and as you can see last group went
all out I have to repeat this because
it's just unimaginable how strong Lasker
played the second part of the tournament
only two rows and six wins against these
strong players and someone wrote in the
comments I don't know I haven't been
able to confirm this but that an emperor
was visiting the tournament and then he
said that five of the players who ranked
best in this tournament emmanuel asked
her how cerkupo Blanc Alexander
relations Ziggler starch and Frank James
Marshall should be awarded a title
greater than that of a chess master that
they should be awarded the title of
let's say a grandmaster and that the
five of them are somehow considered to
be the world's first grandmasters I
haven't been able to really confirm this
but I will research it a bit more and if
I find it to be true we will return to
this but if you have a link to some you
know trustworthy article or something
you can just share it and I will pin it
or give it a heart so everyone can enjoy
it
but yeah that's the game at the bonus
game you know in the middle of the
Capablanca saga I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you are enjoying my coverage of
the Capablanca saga so far
I would like to thank Jonathan Miller
esra by door Richard Yarnell West Carter
and Alexander George for a condition to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
what's a more interesting content gonna
add another bonus video as already
mentioned the names of each vs. Stars
game that should have won the brilliant
surprise until capablanca stole it with
his victory over Bernstein but I still
think it's a very nice game
thank you all and I will see you soon